thank you
[Music]
so this woman in Toledo Ohio who
recently was trying to like sign up for
and apply for some more college classes
just later on in her adult life right
only to learn that she couldn't apply
and it wasn't valid for her application
because um she was actually
half a credit shy of graduating high
school 60 years prior how does that
happen 16 years right bro but the thing
is she also already received a diploma
ironically through and coincidentally
through natural disasters lost it
because it got burnt and stuff like that
but still had a video or photo of it but
the school had no record of this so they
still denied her and now they're saying
that she needs to take some GED classes
in order for her to re-receive her
diploma so she physically graduated has
graduation photos but the school is and
a diploma and they gave her a diploma
yeah and they they have no record of it
you know that's that's kind of happened
to me
so I grew so I graduated the fifth grade
I graduated the fifth grade right you
graduated I graduated that was my last
official walking
and then get this everyone went to this
junior high this public Junior High
called Prairie Perry
I went to a private school
in the district
so I did that and I got kicked out of
eighth grade
and I went to his school got kicked out
of eighth grade
and then so ninth grade my mom goes to
the local high school decide if you got
kicked out of eighth grade twice so
here's the thing when she went to sign
me up I was already in the roster
what wait what exactly so that means
that they they pushed me through the
district Junior High I didn't attend one
day
I was already in the system somehow
so she's signing me up and they're like
yeah you're already in here
and then she's like what how's that
possible all along
yeah and then because I started like
second semester of ninth grade
I didn't even start when everyone
started
dude you're like school history is so
interesting but that's that was the
weirdest thing because it was like in
general yeah but like specifically such
a victim and a beneficiary of corruption
meanwhile there's another JoJo with
somewhere sitting at home like why can't
I [__] sign up yeah yeah
story
huh
my school district was so bad though
that I think like so many kids ditched
and then you know attendance is how they
make money oh so they just push you
forward I think I think the schools were
just pushing makes a lot of sense got it
they're just like he's Japanese he'll
figure it out it makes more sense to the
other Joe just to call it sitting at
home yeah yeah yeah yeah well I think
that could also be a problem both things
can be true
that makes sense yeah so it could be
that because like what if they don't get
enough funding if all these kids are
ditching
wait so like when you didn't go to
school for the first like
your freshman year first half of your
freshman year what were you doing during
that time
homeschooling outside and what were you
doing graffiti drugs yeah
and then um my mom was like you need to
go to school and I'm like yeah I
probably need to go to school so then
she went to go sign me up to register
and then she's like the day that she got
there she went into the parking lot and
she says all these cop cars came in with
their sirens on and all these kids got
out of a car and started booking it and
then she was like so this is the kind of
school my son's gonna go to and then she
signed me up yeah this is in Gardena
that was Gardena High damn yeah and then
she signed you up
she goes home he'll fit in perfectly
here he's gonna love it she was at the
administration thing my name was in
there I was already in the system she's
like how she's like oh they have
on-campus police here good yeah good for
a job oh graffiti everywhere good great
good for jobs here so it could be one of
those things where like they just passed
them through yeah
yup yup that's true oh this happened to
me in uh junior college too when I when
I went to go sign up you never had to go
to school
have not gone probably no I was shy a
few credits but I got to pass and I got
to Trent they would uh I I got accepted
into Cal State LA they let me trans
transfer after my first semester there I
went back and then this [__] male
Karen was talking about how like I'm shy
on transfer credits and this and that
and I'm all like but I'm already
administered in I did my first semester
what are you talking about what can I
just make up the other credits here and
he was being a little dick dude what's
what's a good name for a male character
[__] Kevin Kevin Kevin Newman
on uh nice oh I think like there's
always something messed like stupid
going on with administrations yeah you
know I never picked up my UCI diploma oh
really yeah dude I'll take it they don't
mail it to you yeah you have to go in
there and physically get it right yeah
I'm in office and also I honestly it's
so dumb but I think I never went back
because I probably still have book finds
really yeah you rented from the school I
bet it's like back in the day when we
used to go to school yeah you'd rent
books you don't buy it from [__] take
the books
[Laughter]
because you know there's like you buy
back look buy back yeah so just take the
book
from my backpack I go out and I just
sell it awesome then you do this three
or four times
it's like eight to ten it was a whole
business so you borrowed the book I
didn't borrow the book
do the benches just go to the bookstore
pretend you're reading it you just put
in your bag go outside and just sell it
you're a gangster bro did you go to UCI
too yeah yeah oh yeah you remember you
remember the bookstore right yeah I know
you're right outside they sell the books
how much would you get for the most
stupid like 50 bucks 50 75 bucks those
books are so expensive they're so
expensive that's what makes you feel
like a victimless crime because they're
so inflated that it's like what am I
what am I really doing two to three
times so like what like
10 to 20.
what
like three or four bucks
I didn't make that one
what I do with the money yeah I don't
know spending on like
books food okay everything was expensive
I remember those books being like a
hundred bucks yeah yeah
somewhere like 150 bro textbook when I
was trying to get into UCI they asked me
like what is this semester of Community
College where you have all W's I had
like five withdraws
and I had to explain it I felt like an
idiot what was your explanation because
what happened because uh so it basically
counts as like a failure of a full
submit like that means literally to them
that I failed every class that I was
taking and I was like no it's not quite
that I just didn't go what happened is
uh I was uh it was in the middle of
spring break and I was like oh it's
spring break cool and then I went and
hung out with um from my friend Eris
like the whole week
that after that week I went back to
school no one was there and I went
where's everybody at and they go oh it's
spring break and I was like
spring place this week oh [__] so you
were two on different school systems
yeah so I missed the whole week of
school and then I had to drop all of my
courses because I was so like oh yes my
points had gone so far down because
there were past yeah all testing weeks
too it was like a testing week too yeah
so I just missed everything so I
explained that and they were like that's
kind of a bad mistake to make you're
like come on they're like so why are we
letting you come to this school but
that's relatable come on in yeah you
were like I was on TV
no that doesn't really help damn you
should they gotta see all the credits
and stuff
it only helps when the alumni
association's hell they're trying to get
you to donate money all the time right
so now I'm always getting those emails
you see us Alumni Association Anthony
from kinjas you should join this
Association you guys so there are you
guys uh give back
[__] no oh yeah dude you wouldn't do
that well it's UCI yeah he didn't
respect me when I was there come after
me after this what do you have a name
dude okay what about their dance program
though it's actually good kind of it's
probably a strong dance program but we
weren't part of the official program we
were part of the [__] parking
structure program oh you didn't do the
dance clubs there but was it like cabba
moderns no we did we did this but that
was important they weren't formally a
part of the dance program those were
literally like uh kind of underground
clubs wasn't
um jaw part of the dance program like
she was so she's a copper modern Alum
and she ended up Oh I thought Kaba
modern was like the Key Club like it was
a place there was a lot of dancers that
were on those teams that were part of
the official dance club yeah but they
weren't necessarily like those are like
a lot of classical dance styles and
stuff those programs so you still got to
put together like your like dance thesis
you're performing like the PAC you know
what I mean you have to like do all this
other stuff but then you would want to
Branch out and join these Street teams
for like the College culture hell yeah
dude that's what everyone wanted to be
in as a dancer did you guys ever have to
fundraise to save anything
yeah good question yeah the rec center
yeah every year we were saving the rec
center for the big competition just save
it the competition School tuition didn't
cover the rec center
that was separate
no donors nothing you gotta save it it's
always the same thing the rec center
after the king just honestly yeah nope
okay dude that would be sick what if
would you donate if they renamed the
dance program the Kinja or if they made
it like a building like you can just
build a [__] yeah yeah but that's like
that's the only reason why they make
buildings in these is because of massive
donations what if it's like a massive
donation though would you would it be
worth it yeah we need the money let's
say you had the money let's say you had
two mil yeah they're like oh great it
costs two milk would you might have two
mil I'm not gonna give them 100 exactly
you should [__] no and also would that
be the first thing that you're donating
to or no because I didn't even go to the
dance floor if anything I would donate
not to a Rec Center you see how I would
be like put my name on the parking
structure because that's where we were
the entire time that's down you know
what I'm saying like reading the [__]
parking structure that's sick and then
you can get like so the cars can have
shade it could be a big Asian Rice hat
and it says oh tight for them you are an
Irvine not UCI
well were you guys people don't see ADC
be like what the [__] dude yeah oh yeah
that's true what were you guys in there
Chinese
Association what's cadc Chinese Chinese
Association Dance Crew it's the
stupidest name in the entire circuit it
sounds it sounds official though yeah it
sounded professional to me I was like I
think Cava modern sounds weird what does
it mean what's Kaaba mean I it was part
of the kababayan for short oh that's
Filipino friends like friendships oh
that's cool modern friends modern
friends that are modern like Modern
Family
friend modern yeah
not historical friends Chinese
Association what was it Chinese dance
Association Chinese Association Dance
Crew it's hard to say it sounds kind of
cups seems like you guys do marches just
because of the Chinese Park Chinese and
Association you guys should have done a
communist set it just sounds so formal
dude that would have been dope I don't
know if that would have aged well they
did a Japanese set oh cool really Amy
that was the year before me yeah that's
not really Chinese people yeah yeah
that's my good luck
it was actually a really good set though
it was that was a good thing they pull
out used underwear out of a vending
machine and start putting it on their
faces and
you guys see the drums
they did have a white girl going oh